all right i've got some breaking news
here there's some breaking news now you
may have seen it pop up as a
notification on your phone
elon musk deals with elon musk and his
mega deal to buy twitter this morning
the billionaire tweeted the 44 billion
deal is temporarily on hold he said it's
been delayed pending more details on
fake and spam accounts on the social
media platform twitter did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment about musk's announcement uh so
here's what's going on uh there was a
there was a reuters uh when uh mr musk
tweeted he linked to a reuters article
that suggested that there were less than
five percent of users on twitter that
were spam or bot accounts for some
reason i don't know if it's because he
thinks it's too low or he thinks that
there will be you know there are more
than twitter is announcing uh but that's
apparently why he said he's put this
deal on hold if he doesn't go through
with the deal he'll have to pay a
billion dollar penalty
remember that really yes he would have
to pay a billion dollar penalty it's not
sure how that would work um but he has
put up
tesla stock and he's also sold tesla
stock meanwhile tesla's taken a massive
hit over the last month it's down 30
tesla's his thing twitter is the thing
that he would like to own but tesla is
his real thing and that stock has been
crushed been crushed i've read somewhere
he's lost about 100 billion dollars in
on paper money whereas stocks have come
down in value right bad joke then would
be what's a billion dollars and once
you've lost 100 billion
well exactly but a billion dollars for
him i mean it's a lot of people don't
want to lose a billion dollars don't
want to lose a billion dollars we want
to give the impression that this was
sort of a massive troll that right you
you know this is something that you're
you're you're pitting your desires on
and it's not really that big of a deal
whether or not no no he's always very
strategic i don't know i don't know what
this means though this will be
interesting yeah yeah it would be very
interesting to see what happens